hello everyone I hope you're having an
excellent Friday because it's time for
round 12 of the 2013 candidates
tournament and I thought we would kick
it off with the game everyone is waiting
for Magnus Carlsen versus Vasilyev and
check and I don't know if you remember
their game from the first half of the
tournament it was a very intense game
and event you did get the upper hand but
in the end the game ended in a draw so
let's see let's see how things went this
time yeah there is a quote about the
board that you might not understand
right right at the at the beginning of
this game but you will soon understand
what it means and before we check out
the moves let's check out the standings
once again so after round 11 Carlson is
in first place with seven and a half
points and the lastly one took in
seventh place with four points so I went
for Magnus Carlsen would definitely go a
long way and lastly one who doesn't
he can't win this tournament anymore but
of course he's playing the highest rated
player in the world he wants to play the
best game possible so let's check out
some photos before before we check out
the game ah here we have as usual before
every round a nice photo of
photographers taking the photos of
Magnus Carlsen
then we have here it here he is the man
of the hour
lastly weren't you getting ready for his
game taking a stroll then here another
nice close-up of Vasily von Schuch
having having a nice moment with himself
as usual before every game then we have
another another nice close-up of Vasily
it seems like it's just a usual day you
know cause I'm taking a stroll you want
to not even paying attention to the game
definitely not not like it's around
twelve of the 2013 candidates tournament
and here we have vastly von Schuch could
be checking out someone else's position
but then again it is Vasily you know he
could be just staring at empty space you
know we can never tell so yeah I do hope
you enjoyed those now let's check out
this game Carlson has the white pieces
and that's that's definitely the place
you want to be a leading after eleven
rounds
and having with the white pieces against
lastly von Schuch so II for we have c5
the Sicilian defense Knight f3 knight c6
Knight to c3 so holding off with the
four but only for a movie six now d4c
captures Knight captures and we have the
time uh no variation of the Sicilian
Queen to c7 the bass track of Bishop to
e3 a6 Queen to d2 and knife to f6 now we
have queenside castle by Carlsen Bishop
to b4 and now f3 enforcing that efore
pawn Knight to e7 we have nice the B 3 D
5 and now II five giving the night away
to d7 and preparing f4 so 197 we have F
4 and B 6 event 2 prepares to develop
the light square Bishop Bishop to b4 we
have nice to see 5 a3 attacking the
bishop and now comes Knight to e4
attacking the night the night is also
pinned and also attacking the Queen on D
- so Queen has to move and now comes a
series of exchanges we have Knight
captures Bishop captures Bishop captures
Queen captures and the Queen's come off
the board captures and captures and in
this position Carson said that he he
knew that t1 was better I mean just by
looking at the pawn structure you can
realize this but he didn't think it was
anything significant and then he thought
that you know the you can check it out
in an interview after the game there
will be a link as usual in the
description below cost authority Manju
she just continued developing but here
evant you played a5 and here cross and
thought that this move was weakening the
Queen side a bit too much and the engine
definitely agrees with him and it was at
this point that Carson decided to play
for a win so tonight the before we have
Bishop to e6 Bishop to d3 now if he
wants to capture the bishop then Carson
will undable his C pawn king 37 1032
we have a nice to see 6 and rook to be 1
attacking the the backwards b6 bone
Bishop captures King captures now and
we have rook rook to b8 you could
capture with the pawn the seemingly
under bows your pawns but then knife
capture some before and then you would
have a double deep on so it doesn't
really fix the problem King captures on
d3 now rook to b8 defending the b6 pawn
and here comes a move that cousin
characterizes after after the game and I
will probably use this as a title of the
video he says that this move that he
played was extremely stupid those were
the words he used he says that he can
play pretty much anything here there's
no reason to do this it seems like a
very powerful move the knight is coming
to d6 it's a very active square but here
eventually finds amazing counter play
inventor plays g5 of course you don't
want to play something like F character
some g5 that leaves your ePHI point
undefended constantly g3 and now comes
Rock h2 g8 and now you will get a lot of
activity for this rook we have c4
Carlson wants to get rid of his he's a
weak pawn
G cappers on f4 I will have G captures
on f4 and Knight to e7 now we have rook
to g1 opposing Avant of stroke and g8 d
captures on c4 Kim captures on c4 and
now Knight to d5 attacking the weak f4
pawn Knight to d6 and here came to c6 by
module you can't capture the point
immediately if you capture it
immediately with Knight captures and i-4
then rook captures of course row
captures and then the b6 bone is
undefended and rook after some b6 pretty
much fixes everything for white so after
Knight to d6 King to c6 now the king is
defending the b6 pawn Knight captures on
f7 Knight captures on f4 and now came to
b3 we have King to c5 Knight to g5 h 6
we have Knight to e4 this comes with
check and King to d4 now nice to have 6
again attacking the rook and now rook
captures an g1 rook captures and g1 and
rook to CH now we have rook to e1 Carson
is threatening rook to e4 to win to win
even jokes night on f4 so you have to
do something about this event took place
route the c3 check King to be - and now
rook to f3 defending the knight we have
rook to e4 check King to c5 and now
Knight to d7 also this comes with check
but came to d5
you cannot grab the pawn because now
your rook is under attack so Carson
repeats Knight to f6 check event also
repeat scheme to c5 and a cross and once
again repeats Knight to d7 check and
here if Evandro would repeat into d5
then it would be a threefold repetition
and the game would end in a draw but
here it's actually a von Schuch who
refuses the draw and place king to c6 he
attacks the knight Knight to f6
we have Knight to g6 and rook the c4 now
this comes with check pink the b5 and
now rook to e4 rook to a5 with a double
attack on the e5 pawn and here knife to
e8 cousin tries to trick him and took in
going for the pawn now if you capture it
with real characters and e5 then Knight
the c7 this comes with the check King to
c6 and then rook captures on e5 Knight
captures and the knife captors on e6 so
the material is once again equal the
pawn structure is a bit better for black
but it's it's hard to say if black can
actually win this probably not
so after this knife to e8 move King to
c5 first by watch I'm not allowing this
night to c7 check nice to see seven and
now comes Knight captures on e5 and this
is the problem now Carson doesn't have
the option of capturing the pawn because
now if you capture this with check you
get King to d5 and here Carson would
lose a piece you do have to move the
rook you have to remove the root King
captures you are down a piece so after
Knight to e5 rook to h4 first going for
the h6 pawn but King to d6 first event
took attacks crossings night a nice the
b5 check we have king to d7 and now a
four again you can't afford to capture
the h6 pawn if you capture it then you
get night to f7 a very nice idea
attacking the rook and also the knight
on b5 so again you lose a piece even if
you pin a bunch of snide here then rock
capture some b5 this comes with check
King has to move and then you simply
protect the night again you wrap a piece
so after King d7 who have a four first
defending the night now rock captors and
h6 is a threat but now event you seem to
place h5 and he he won a clean point so
can can you want to play this out to a
win can he converted to a full point
this one point advantage well let's see
nice to d4 attacking the rook we have
rook to g5 rook to e4 now and night the
c5 Knight to c4 this comes with two
check King to c3 attacking the knight
and now rook to e5 offering a trade of
rooks now rook captures if rook captures
Knight captures it's a pawn up still one
night each but even cook is very
confident in his ability to convert to
this and Qasim believes him so cross and
refuses rook to h4 we have Knight to d6
and now King to d3 Rock the d5 and this
knight is pinned of course and if a van
truck is able to play something like
Knight to f5 and exchange both nights
and rooks then four against three that's
a completely winning endgame a king at
four points is of course winning against
King and three points so c4 attacking
the rook rook to g5 and now comes Knight
to f3 attacking the rook on g5 rope the
c5 and here comes Knight to d2 rook to a
five nights the b3 and now Knights the
b7 avenge of now plans to play Knight to
c5 which will force a trade of knights
as da for pawn will be impossible to
defend
so rook to h3 we have King to d6 King to
c3 and now comes a nice to see five and
you do have to trade nights because
there is no way for you to actually
defend the DA for pawn so Knight
captures King captures and now comes
roof to e3 and and e4 e5 and the one
troop is again very confident in his
ability to win this rook ending being
only upon up
and it's very interesting what technique
the avenge of uses so h4 we have King
2d6
rook the d3 with check King e6 product
to g3 King to f6 not allowing rook to g6
check but now cross and tries rope to b3
going for rope to d6 check to pick up
the b6 pawn rook to f4 now allowing rook
to d6 check but Dani bunch will pick up
the h4 porn so rook comes with check
kinks King to f5 and now route capture
some b6 rook captures on h4 again he one
ship is a pawn and now c5 Carlsen starts
pushing his best pawn rook captures on
a4 and here rook to h6 comes if I shook
said in an entry after the game that
c6 was was probably a better move and
that c6 could have saved white but the
engine doesn't doesn't agree with
caution in this position so rook to h6
we have King to e4 and rook the d6 now
came to deform offering a trade we have
rook to a 6 and now rook to d5 rook
captures on a 5 and now rook the c4
check King moves and now rook captures
of course a cross and cannot allow to
exchange rooks so rope to a 4 we have
ripped the c7 rope to h4 attacking the
h4 h5 pawn rook to h7 defending King to
e3 and now constant of course wants to
set up a blockade and this is a very
exciting how event took converts
disposition King to e6 came to before
now rook to h8 came back to e3 and now
King to f5 now the King has to escort
the H pawn king to e2 King to g5
attacking the rook rook to e4 now
Carlson will try to switch places
so the rook will block the e pawn and he
will try to block the H bone with the
king
rook to e8 defending the pawn and now
into e3 we have H for Kim to e2 we have
h3 team to f2 the King has to stay in
the square of the pawn h2 King to g2 and
now
rook to a ruku h8 you can't play this
because the RO captures only five of
course comes with two checks so what do
you do here it's a very interesting
position and why did avant you do this
why did you push this point all the way
here so nothing can protect it so you
don't even have to pause the video of
course you see what the idea is here if
once you've played pawn to h1 and we
promoted it to a queen why did he do it
well King captures on h1 now comes King
to d5 a king to f5 attacking the rook
rook has to move rook to e1 was played
and now comes rope to g8
this was the whole point of forcing the
King to h1 now the rook is completely
cutting off the team from the game and
there is really nothing this rook can do
against a king and phone King 2h 2 was
played King before with rook to f1 check
King III and it was in this position and
move 90 that magnus carlsen
resigned the game what if you resign
well there's really nothing to do the
king will come to d2 for example and
then simply pushing the pawn wins the
game straight away so yeah this could be
very well be the first game
well other than that game eventual
played against girlfriend where they had
a 17 move draw that lasted I believe
half an hour this is the first normal
game everyone who played in determine
that he wasn't in time trouble and
especially that he didn't lose because
he ran out of time and of course it's
the first game Magnus Carlsen lost in
this tournament so around 12 against
even Chuck Colson with the white pieces
he went to good black Carlsen loses his
first game in this tournament and he
takes a pretty hard blow since he is
leading the tournament and now depending
on how players who are trying to catch
up to him for example Vladimir Kramnik
play out their game it will you know
affect the the standings dramatically
but we will get that when we check out
some of the other games from round 12 of
the 2013 candidates tournament so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and yeah this is something calls and
said in an interview but you are very
welcome to check it out there is a link
in the description below where you can
check out all the interviews after all
the games from the
2013 candidates tournament Carson said
that he thinks that he played
disgracefully from move 1 which is I
mean Carson played an excellent game but
eventually didn't make a single mistake
so something a word worth saying so you
know all of the moves event you played
were like the top top top candidate
moves so yeah once again I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check - all
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
another interesting game from round 12
of the 2013 Canada's tournament see you
soon and have an excellent Friday